evaluate 3x squared minus 8x plus seven  when X is equal to negative two so to  evaluate this expression when X is equal  to negative two everywhere that we see  an X we just have to substitute it with  a negative two so it would be three  times instead of x squared would be  three times negative two squared minus  eight times instead of eight times X  eight times negative two plus seven and  so what does this give us so we have  three times negative two squared well  that's just positive 4 negative times a  negative is a positive minus 8 times  negative 2 is negative 16 negative 16  plus 7 so 3 times 4 is 12  your sum from that you're subtracting  negative 16 subtracting negative 16 is  the same thing as adding positive 16 so  it's 12 plus 16 plus 7 and so this is  equal to 12 plus 16 is 28 and then if  you add 7 to 28 you get you get 35